so what if i told you covet made us  lazier what if i told you during covid  the harder working won even more but the  laser got lazier you may ask why think  about it this way  pre-covet you and i would go sit with  somebody face to face and run an  appointment with them right kovit made  us just say i'm just gonna do zoom i'm  just gonna do zoom i sat with an  investment banker who's a direct  competitor goldman sachs and i said tell  me how the last two years were he says  goldman sachs took our lunch no matter  what our boss says they took our lunch i  said why he says because the boss of  goldman said get on the jet go meet the  entrepreneur raise the money let the  other guys just do zoom but we're gonna  go meet with the entrepreneur that's why  goldman kicked everyone's ass during  covet so for some of you that maybe took  a step back maybe it's time to go back  and sit down face to face with the  customer like you did pre-kobe